[Musique]
o oh
quoi mais qu'est-ce que c'est ce truc là
oh
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce que c'est
j'en sais rien il y a plein de trucs sur
un chariot du matériel médical je
croyais et et il y a une de
verceuse un cragotome j'en ai rien à
de ce truc
Cécilien comm si une sorte de Magneto
c'est écrit écoutez-moi je toucherai
pas
bonjour
Matthéo
mal au secours c'est votre faute c'est
vous qui m'avez mis là dedans c'est à
cause de vous prends-toi un peu gabille
oh non c'est moi qui suis accro à
l'oxycodone
peut-être Gabriella sera la
suivante
quoi parfois on se retrouve englué dans
des choses qui je vous en prie qui vont
à l'encontre de notre nature les drogues
sont aussi pernicieuses qu'elles sont
puissantes
nous sommes libres de nos choix
Gabriella a eu le choix de
refuser si tu n'arrives pas à gérer ça
comment comptes-tu aller au bout de
notre
[Musique]
uvre